breaking news meine Damen und Herren
denn die erste flutbilanz der
Bundesregierung liegt vor wir haben das
Papier gerade bekommen im Juli wir
erinnern uns trifft die Flut Deutschland
zerstörthäuser straßenbahntrassen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Rheinland-Pfalz
Sachsen und Bayern über 800 Menschen
werden verletzt
183 sterben jetzt liegt dieses Papier
von innen und Finanzministerium vor dass
das ganze Ausmaß deutlich macht der
Zwischenbericht der Flutkatastrophe 2021
und wir wollen jetzt mal auf die
wichtigsten Aspekte darauf schauen
Patricia die Schäden die werden nämlich
beziffert die Schäden der
Privathaushalte belaufen sich auf 14,3
Milliarden Euro bei der staatlichen
Infrastruktur also Brücken
straßenzugverbindungen zum Beispiel
liegt die Summe der Schäden bei 17
Milliarden Euro das System des
Bevölkerungsschutzes hat sich laut des
Papiers als Zitat grundsätzlich trag und
leistungsfähig erwiesen etwas was wir in
dieser Sendung gleich besprechen werden
von Fehlern die gemacht wurden steht
nämlich nichts in dem Zwischenbericht
des Innen- und Finanzministeriums also
grundsätzlich trag- und leistungsfähig
so heißt es hier wörtlich trotzdem solle
das System des Bevölkerungsschutzes aber
weiter evaluiert werden wie es heißt
also zu deutsch es muss noch mal geprüft
werden nichts falsch gemacht
also wir kommen offensichtlich nicht aus
diesem Behörden Deutsch Behörden
Deutschland raus wenn das die Tonalität
dieses Gutachtens sie sich verstehe dass
das nicht geschrieben ist wie in
spannende Thriller oder ein Roman aber
wenn dort in den Fokus gerückt wird wie
viel Milliarden Schaden entstanden ist
ohne auch auf die Frage einzugehen oder
beziehungsweise bis wirft die Frage auf
wer bezahlt es denn dann eigentlich und
wenn es dann gipfelt in zwei Sachen dass
wenn ich das richtig sehe von den Toten
irgendwie kein Wort da drin steht und
das auch nicht drin steht
das ist krasse Fehler gab das ist
aufgedeckt dass die Infrastruktur
unseres Landes nicht in der Lage ist auf
Katastrophen zu reagieren das ist
sozusagen ein ein Symbol ist es uns
aufwecken muss unsere Infrastrukturen
komplett zu überdenken wenn das alles in
dem Wort wir müssen das jetzt halt ein
bisschen evaluieren gipfelt dann ist ist
schon der Einstieg in die Aufarbeitung
wieder schief gegangen
evaluieren heißt es immer wieder wir
haben damals über die Flut berichtet
Klaus haben diese Bilder gesehen die
Verzweiflung der Menschen die Zerstörung
und auch noch heute stehen so viele
Menschen vor den Trümmern ihrer Existenz
sie schauen jetzt in den Winter haben
zum Teil keinen Strom haben kein warmes
Wasser und haben zum Teil auch immer
noch kein Zuhause und auch keine Hilfe
und jetzt bekommt man das Schwarz auf
Weiß und es steht drin ja wir müssen
noch einmal evaluieren also ich finde es
ist ein Schlag ins Gesicht der direkt
Betroffenen und es ist auch ein Schlag
ins Gesicht aller Bürger die sich darauf
verlassen wollen dass dieser Staat in
Krisensituationen in Notsituationen für
uns da ist ich sehe gerade dafür
bezahlen wir ihn dafür bezahlen wir
unsere Steuern und dafür wählen wir
seine Vertreter und dann müssen glaube
ich diese Menschen auch in der
Aufarbeitung erstens ein bisschen
Emotionalität zeigen ehrliche nicht
geheuchelte und zweitens müssen sie ihre
eigenen Fehlleistungen für diese
verantwortlich sind auch benennen sonst
kann man sie nämlich nicht lösen ich
habe später mal ein bisschen geblättert
während ihr gesprochen habt und in der
Tat immerhin muss man sagen es steht
hier und das ist andererseits an
brutales Eingeständnis dass deutsche
hilfeleistungssystem verdankt seine
Leistungsstärke in erster Linie den
zahlreichen ehrenamtlichen Helferinnen
und Helfern
die haben ja einen tollen Job gemacht
aber es wird auch wenn ich das jetzt
ganz brandneu durch uns kommt diese
Nachricht der sozusagen erst unter die
Leute wir werden es gleich im Nachgang
mal studieren aber es muss doch irgendwo
klar werden dass krasse Fehler passiert
sind das ist große Defizite gab das
alles was wir jetzt rauslesen und hören
klingt so als wäre eigentlich alles im
großen und ganzen ganz gut gelaufen aber
es gibt halt paar hunder Tote und Haufen
Milliarden Schäden noch interessanter
Punkt welcher die Zuständigkeit der
Länder also der Föderalismus für den
Katastrophenschutz hat sich auch bei der
Bewältigung des Hochwassers in diesem
Jahr bewährt also wenn wir jetzt noch
vier Absätze Vorlesen wo sich irgendwas
bewährt hat wäre ich verrückt also es
wäre am Ende wenn man das durchgelesen
hat ist man sediert und denkt das war
gar nichts sehr toll gelaufen es war
wirklich sensationell gut wie wir das
alles gemacht haben diese Idioten von
Journalisten die sich darüber aufregen
diese Weicheier und Memmen von Menschen
die einen Häusern abgesoffen sind und
tote betrauert haben da war doch gar
nichts wir haben uns bewährt es hat sich
bewahrheitet das richtig ist wir müssen
ein bisschen rum evaluieren aber im
Großen und Ganzen hat doch alles
geklappt und wisst ihr was jetzt in
meinem Kopf ist gab es nicht sogar den
Satz von Frau Merkel im Großen und
Ganzen hat alles geklappt zur Pandemie
das war eine einer ihrer Sätze zur
Pandemie und der ist im Grunde auch
wieder reingerutscht in die Aufarbeitung
der Flut was ist denn mit uns los
[Musik]